Yeah children grow up with children around the area although we're six kilometers they have newman
and their children attended to copy camp. Local school here. Don our youngest girl did go to nimbin high school.
And they were. They played sport. And everything in nimble. With and against the local. All the alternate you'll run.
And there was no problem and i think. The children are they mind.
Thing that we've got to look at for to assimilate both groups. Into a better. Functioning community. Well.
For years has been from low points and high points in. Year.
From a low point of view in some of the and a very small percentage i've got to emphasize of the alternative.
Are extremists. And when it comes to such is it a local just likely in the story to just being in. Installed now.
We've had right arguments against it. We've had community consultation and.
Unfortunately the extremist will not accept a democratic vote in other words a majority vote
and they're still campaigning against it.
And we've had a situation where one of them's even said that when the sort
when the public toilets will be filled with cement when it is finished are that some of the low points.
But the high points are when they all turn at them so. Taking part in community affairs and i mean.
The community face much of progress associations right part associations
and taking an active part in the community affairs. And that is the biggest proportion of them. And i do not want.
Extremists at all. I would rather do without them and. It is i.
A situation where i think the high point really out why the low point and.
I'm happy to be a member of the newman community are going to show you. So.
Yes a
and i think that's probably one of the worst situations that all of the disadvantages probably all the aquarius first
of all it's. Stigmatized. The village as a hippie. Capital of the strata.
Not only the state and that is something i don't think that the community will ever live day on. It is something that.
As i mentioned a while ago the alternative don't even want that stigmatized and that why i think the other.
Down one is the drugs thing the did follow the aquarius festival on a budget can't all be blamed on it
but it's different from that tong and.
It's a problem that started to take a lot to overcome
but there are quite a few organizations in the community at the present stage.
Campaigning with the police and the local state
and federal government to try to do something about it to clean it up the street thing is not very very good at all of
the presidents died. And i think that is the one bad thing really that kind. From as well as the stigma ties. Asian.
It came from the quest festival that it's going to take a lot to live down. So it's.
Well it's got the image that if you want an easy life with something like this to come to newman it's there. And.
I live far enough out of newman. Not to be caught up in a too much as i said six kilometers or why. But it is not good.
On the street at the present stage and. Talking to developers that are developing around him.
At the president's day you're coming in contact with this.
When they're trying to sell properties when they're trying to sell a box full building.
They're coming against a little bit of animosity or. Rebellion to be the wrong word against.
Bombing i block in newman and that's one of the things that i think it's got to be overcome. And.
It'll need a lot of work. While the alternative. Why the local community.
To overcome all these problems but i think it can be done. Once. It's. Only the extremists. Not wanting any change.
They the majority of the alternatives saudi most certainly don't mind any great change providing the environment is
looked after providing all the ordinances of the council are abided by there doesn't seem to be any problem with them.
But there is i. A section. And i said they. They extremists. Don't want any change whatever.
And even campaign at a local auction a stopping market until people got to bali. What things.
Probably the nice things that i've had a complaint against the. The extremists.
Would be a situation where multiple occupancies. On properties. And on my own counsel that i've had lots of problems.
I've got nothing against multiple occupancy at all providing that they have got community titles.
Providing all the ordinance of council are abided by. And all the recommendations laid down for fire control.
For environment control are abided by.
Exactly the same as any other developers required to do that unfortunately has not been done by a lot of the multiple
occupancy. In the area. Now there are in the police district sixty seven multiple occupancies.
They're not all legal some of the been done in the county don't even know anything about them.
So we've got a real big problem was filed multiple awkwardly duncanson some of which.
Legal and some of which are working and functioning exceptionally well.
And i've got no problem with them at all but i certainly have a problem with that.
Any of the one to not abiding by council ordinances. The building codes. They hold.
Provisions for the it for the sake of the environment. Of the community. So.
He's history and had multiple options to be guided right away back to the nine hundred seventy three seventy four
when a tunnel falls coordinate
and cooperate of come into being mediterranean shark council it was the first one on the.
I think the whole of the northeast corner at least of the state of new south wilds.
And it was like a guinea pig being a council on the council that time. Had a job to come to grips with it and.
It got off the ground. Not unanimous but what a six count was on the council.
But a mind thing that's why indeed majority of the councils where they said that they want to do their own thing.
And look after themselves.
Don't tie gainey part in community affairs and have no problem say and i want to do their own thing
and get off that ult. Now that's why the whole council not the whole council but the majority of council to vote.
To let it go ahead. Since that time we've had i the history of multiple occupancy and. And the council.
It has been fragmented.
Whole lot has been illegal buildings go up there's been threats of taking him down with the bulldozer.
We have the on bud's minute stepped in and a couple of occasions we have had.
Ministers of the state stepping in on terrible occasions and. There have not been a good ideas on between.
Building codes hilt. Regulations. With multiple occupancies and with the councils.
Even now the lismore city council which are has in effect most of these multiple documentaries.
Or i suppose one of the worst examples i can think of at the present studied that mean quite a few.
But one of the worst examples was i would turn my knee a creek.
And i think i'm right in their wallets and road i'm sorry that's the one we had lots of problems over there and.
With mine and we even had about three council inspections with all alderman and administration staff and.
We just could not get off the ground. That we tried to force the ordinances on them.
And the on budget and other ministers of state to step in and stop is doing any real thing about it
and that's what i feel that it has not been a good thing as far as state and local government.
Relationships are concerned. When i wouldn't back. The local government.
Up in we were trying to rectify a problem that was caused by multiple occupancy development. Illegal buildings.
They are not even a development application or building up like i can put into council. I had houses. Resting on.
Logs on the ground that. Fall in the forest. They had houses built in the forest with not opposed.
At least a meter of material that. Combustion material that would burn at the least thing to start it off and.
We just couldn't get into their heads that they needed protection.
I had no protection them so they expected the council to provide everything. That some of the really bad cases.
All of them of not being that bad. This time and the other one across the other side of it. That was the argument.
And i certainly that. Blamed a lot of white. To have the concession that the council. That they got away with council.
But i don't believe that they should be treated any other different to any other one they've got to abide by their
regulations.
And most certainly the regulations regarding multiple documented all these type of building it most certainly is law.
So i feel it's lower than than the other building for any other developer that developing in the community.
Now they shouldn't be treated any differently at all like in other words.
Irrespective of what the building conditions are if they agreed to that they must do it and.
Unfortunately they go ahead and put a put i building up that doesn't conform in any shape or form.
And then we've got or will the council has big problems and. Whether they can pull it down or knock it down and.
Which things were very very. Not in this council but in the local in the.
The neighboring council of goggle weird i've had to please dean and. There's been very very big. Unrest over.
In three or four day program. Of pulling the houses apart and council having to do that. So yes.
It is a very drastic measure but however i believe that they bring it on themselves when they don't boy.
Abide like they greet to in the first place to get the development.
And then when they get the development they go ahead and do whatever they want to do. And that is wrong. Yes. You say.
Yes but he and i agree what you saya but how we have.
They've been here and there that they are not causing any problem for anyone else either.
And some of them are taking part in the community affairs
and hoping to shape the community as i would like to see it done and that ought to like to see them all doing.
Instead of the extremists getting out and.
Lying down in front of bulldozers or or chainsaws or something to that effect. But.
Yes some of the buildings that were inspected. Left a hell of a lot to be desired and. They were an old reason.
I'll buy olds and. Even cream sheds.
And things like it to start it off and they were slapped up a bit of blue plastic
and stuff like at the on the only thing they had from where the board but they'd be the worst ones.
There were the others that almost. Would conform to building regulations but they never ever got permission to do it.
And that was a problem they didn't want to get permission they just went ahead. But if they had of went ahead.
They or their house would have been very noble to be. To be modified. Without any real great effort on their pop.
To my get fit the building codes and that they didn't do. Are you can't hear.
They local policeman was called on to the young.
Showground to talk to a fellow all put a following that was causing a disturbance at the local child
or up to the local shop. And he would have had to have a bottle of tequila and a bottle of scotch and..
And a better king of beer to get in the condition he was seen and heard running around brandishing i.e. Acts.
In his hand.
So i mean my local policeman you who it was so he got about three more pleased to connect them is more and i went down.
And the local policeman even they only went up to him and he said.
You come on and are got to take you up to the play station.
If that's all right he said he said take me in
and getting my eat all of it i tried to view him a little bit of a police baton and he didn't across the need.
That usually bring them down on in these pretty quickly baseball i never even turned i. Muscle.
He put the met in these other hand he did because the other night.
And they follow looked at he said look mighty said if i were you he said i put that away before i do something with it.
And he did. You never even feel duty that the job of that or you to call him. Now you to call him a indian.
Indian something you're the big man they take you to three bottles.
The killer the game and let's not had any running along the street with the ex and frightening at everyone
but never hurt anyone but the local policeman didn't like him at all he thought he said you were dangerous with cancer.
So he put the baton back in the thing like you and acting politely to get in the. In the vein we did.
I suppose one of the great characters and you're probably interviewing him. The fellow called harry ending.
Harry comes from tunnel force coordination cooperative he's been there since nineteen seventy two seventy three.
Harry was always very thin we always thought that harry would never see the next winter.
But harry
and lisa cohen the truck driver could use to drive the truck that used to go to brisbane bring back their supplies.
Of vegetables and stuff.
However we all didn't how we'd see the next winter yet each year when part was over the next we'd all get him.
And we have a hairy ending of.
I think he's president of the progress association of the present stage he does a lot for community affairs he does a
lot for people in sport and he helps kids and money another and. To my knowledge kerry did not marry.
And i can assure you we had one fine gentleman was harry any better he's one of the old identities of nimbin that.
Everyone in human. Likes and appreciates he's a tremendous fellow he looked up to everyone in human.